[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit mir
drei serien schönen guten abend zusammen
sportliches später wieder mit katja
stresow wir blicken vor und zurück und
nennt hier sind unsere themen an diesem
donnerstag
ein block gegen den westen china und
russland versuchen gemeinsam ihren
einfluss auszubauen
sorge vor dem winter hausärzte warnen
vor einer grippewelle und werben für
eine doppel impfung mit dem neuesten
corona impfstoff
und große emotionen beim fernsehpreis am
ende einer bunten show freut sich iris
berben über den preis für ihr lebenswerk
seit dem krieg zeichnet es sich immer
stärker ab die welt teilt sich in neue
blöcke in diesem zusammenhang heute ein
bemerkenswerter termin in usbekistan
dort das treffen einer organisation
bestehend aus ländern die engen
zusammenarbeiten wollen und sich dabei
als gegengewicht zu westlichen
bündnissen verstehen zu den mitgliedern
gehören china russland indien fünf
weitere asiatische länder und ab jetzt
offiziell auch der iran mehr als 40
prozent der weltbevölkerung sind so
vertreten und genauso spannend bei dem
treffen heute kamen erstmals seit dem
ukraine krieg der russische präsident
putin und chinas präsident schied
zusammen miriam stein berichtet
sah markant eine der ältesten städte der
welt herz der alten seidenstraße
es ist die kulisse für diesen gipfel bei
dem es um mehr geht als um schöne bilder
seit beginn des ukraine kriegs ist es
das erste treffen der präsidenten
russlands und chinas und sie haben ein
großes ziel
internationale ordnung auch gemeinsam
und somit mit partnern so zu reformieren
dass eben der autokratische starken
china und russland einen raum daran
finden sie stärkt putin den rücken beim
thema ukraine und putin stärkt ihm den
rücken beim thema teil an ihr ziel
eine neue weltordnung
das außenpolitische tante moskau peking
spielt eine schlüsselrolle bei der
sicherung der globalen und regionalen
stabilität
es ist der gipfel der autokraten auch
iran soll künftig als vollwertiges
mitglied dazu gehören
für ihn ist es die erste auslandsreise
seit beginn der korona pandemie dafür
hat er ein angenehmes ziel gewählt china
hat in zentralasien viel investiert und
gute beziehungen zu den staatsführern
diese bühne nutzt er um diplomatisch
gegengewichte zu setzen zum beispiel
gegen die vereinten nationen oder er
deutlich dominierte plattform so zeigte
das heute das russische
verteidigungsministerium
in einem video von einer gemeinsamen
übung der chinesischen und russischen
marine in markant sagte china sei bereit
sich mit russland gegenseitig in fragen
von kerninteressen energisch zu
unterstützen und gemeinsam als neuer
blog die welt zu ordnen
wir wollen in moskau nachfragen bei
phoebe was erwartet putin was erwartet
russland in dieser situation von china
in moskau hat bisher eigentlich immer
darauf geachtet nicht zu tief in die
abhängigkeit von china hineinzugeraten
aber jetzt sieht man sich hier
angesichts der weit reichenden
sanktionen die der westen aufgrund des
russischen einmarsches in die ukraine
verhängt hat einer gewissen
alternativlosigkeit gegenüber russland
braucht autos maschinenbauteile
mikrochips alles mögliche was der westen
jetzt nicht mehr liefert und china ist
bis zu einem gewissen grad auch bereit
moskaus hoffnung hier zu erfüllen der
handel zwischen den beiden ländern der
ist angestiegen und china kauft zum
beispiel jetzt auch mehr russisches gas
als zuvor und so kommt natürlich
wichtiges notwendiges geld in putins
kasse allerdings hat chinas
unterstützung grenzen nämlich genau da
wo die volksrepublik gefahr laufen würde
selbst in den sog der russland
sanktionen hineinzugeraten und chinas
unterstützung hat auch einen preis auf
offener bühne da lässt man russland das
gesicht wahren aber hinter den kulissen
da sind sich viele experten und
expertinnen einig
da diktiert china die die bedingungen
der beziehung danke für die einordnung
nach moskau für begann war das ja diese
ganzen entwicklungen die sind mit
weiteren kriegs gefahren verbunden wie
darauf die bundeswehr reagieren könnte
darum geht es seit heute bei einer
bundeswehrtagung den ton den setzte am
morgen der sprecher des
bundeswehrverbandes der die truppe nach
wie vor in schlechter verfassung sieht
trotz der versprochenen zusätzlichen 100
milliarden gleichzeitig kündigt die
verteidigungsministerin weitere waffen
für die ukraine an andrea maurer
zwei dieser maß mehrfach raketenwerfer
plus munition 50 dieser als schutz
transport fahrzeuge vom typ dingo so
sieht die neue deutsche hilfe für die
gerade erfolgreiche ukraine aus die die
ministerin heute verkündet diese
tatsache und erfolgreiche
operationsführung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte macht notwendig zeigt wie
wichtig es ist der ukraine auch weiteres
militärgerät schnell zur verfügung zu
stellen die ausbildung ukrainischer
kräfte soll im september beginnen
geliefert wird aus beständen der
bundeswehr für den chef des
bundeswehrverbandes ist eine rote linie
überschritten alle wissen dass es oft
genug gesagt nicht nur dass die
bundeswehr nahezu planck ist die
ministerin hat betont die depots in leer
wir haben keine ersatzteile kaum
munition wir haben enorme herausholen
mit den nato verpflichtungen und
deswegen ist vollkommen klar aus der
bundeswehr selbst kann nichts mehr
geliefert werden in richtung ukraine
während die ministerin heute auf die
militärischen erfolge der ukraine
verweist warnt deutschlands ranghöchster
soldat davor russlands militärische
stärke zu unterschätzen bei der
bewertung des russischen militär
potenzials allerdings sollten wir
unseren blick nicht nur auf die ukraine
lenken auch wenn etwa 60 prozent der
landstreitkräfte russische streitkräfte
im ukrainischen gebunden sind verfügen
die restlichen landstreitkräfte sowie
die russische marine und
luftstreitkräfte noch über ungebundene
kapazitäten einer lieferung von schützen
und kampfpanzern um die die ukraine
deutschland bittet könig lambrecht nicht
an morgen ist hier eine rede von kanzler
scholz geplant
eu-kommissionschef in von der leyen hat
der ukraine anhaltende unterstützung
zugesagt und zu den militärischen
erfolgen gratuliert bei ihrem inzwischen
dritten besuch seit kriegsbeginn mit
präsident lee lenski sprach sie in kiew
vor allem über hilfen und
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit auch der
beitrittsprozess zur eu sei auf einem
guten weg so von der leyen
nach zwei tagen schwerer kämpfe zwischen
armenien und aserbaidschan gibt es jetzt
zeichen der entspannung beide seiten
halten sich an eine vereinbarte
waffenruhe
sie war gestern abend unter
internationaler vermittlung zustande
gekommen
beide länder streiten seit jahrzehnten
um die region berg karabach die
völkerrechtlich zu aserbaidschan gehört
aber von armenisch unterstützten
separatisten kontrolliert wird
die antworten auf die krisen unserer
zeit gemeinsam so das ziel der
sogenannten konzertierten aktion einem
treffen der bundesregierung mit
vertretern aus wirtschaft und von
gewerkschaften das schon zum zweiten mal
stattfindet die bundesregierung hat mit
ihren entlastungs paketen schon
vorgelegt trotzdem gibt es weitere
erwartungen über die ergebnisse nicole
diekmann
rund zwei stunden lief runde zwei der
sogenannten konzertierten aktion
anschließend auftritt von kanzler und
vertretern von gewerkschaften und
arbeitgebern erhoffte signal gemeinsam
und entschlossen im kampf gegen die
krise wir haben heute themen besprochen
wir uns alle um tragen viele sorgen sich
wegen der stark steigenden preise viele
spüren die inflation beim einkaufen im
supermarkt an der tankstelle bei der
heizkostenabrechnung
auch die betriebe geraten wegen hoher
energiekosten immer mehr unter druck
einigkeit habe geherrscht betonte man
heute wobei man strittige themen wie
lohnerhöhungen auch aus geklammert hatte
neben dem lob für die rettungspakete der
regierung allerdings dann doch die klare
ansage der gewerkschaften das reicht
nicht es muss aber aus unserer sicht
auch eine weitere politische flankierung
geben durch eine zweite energiepreis
pauschale über 500 euro plus 100 euro
pro kind an dieser stelle bedarf es dann
sicherlich noch weitere gespräche aus
uns weiterer gespräche bedarf es auch
über das kurzarbeitergeld und über die
bis zu 3000 euro die arbeitgeber steuer
und abgabenfrei an ihre mitarbeiter
auszahlen dürfen ist jedoch wichtig
festzuhalten dass nicht alle unternehmen
diese einmalzahlungen leisten können
viele betriebe stehen gerade am
wirtschaftlichen abgrund
wenig konkretes wenig neues heute nach
102 der konzertierten aktion
im november will man sich wieder treffen
mit den kosten der krise beschäftigt
sich auch maybrit illner heute im zdf ab
22 uhr 15 und welche produkte besonders
stark im preis steigen das können sie
bei uns im internet nachlesen auf zdf
heute beziehungsweise in unserer
mediziner und apotheker raten zum
heutigen deutschen hausärzte tag zu
neuen impfungen zum einen gegen korona
und zum anderen aber auch gegen die
grippe die sei wegen fast drei corona
jahren zuletzt in den hintergrund
gerückt und deswegen nötig weil
möglicherweise eine heftige grippewelle
droht mehr von roman leskovar
der andrang überschaubar in berlins
impfzentrum seit dieser woche wird der
omicron angepasste impfstoff gespritzt
auch wenn eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission noch aussteht hier
verunsichert das niemanden meine frau
schwanger und da dachte ich so was kann
ich denn noch machen damit sie ein
bisschen frech ein bisschen besser
schützen kann damit ich mich mehr
schützen oder länger schütze und ja
eigentlich wollte ich auf den ganz neuen
partner wird da weiß man ja nicht wann
er kommt das bereits erhältliche serum
enthält bestandteile der omicron
variante baa1 in deutschland
zirkulierten zuletzt aber die varianten
b a 4 und der a 5 auch dafür hat die eu
einen impfstoff zugelassen
die auslieferung könnte kommende woche
beginnen nach meinung von hausärzten
müssten risikopatienten aber nicht
darauf warten wichtig ist die leute die
einen fortgeschrittenes alter mit
chronischer graben zu impfen und mit dem
sie offen was jetzt zur verfügung steht
und das ist nun mal der b1 b2 adaptierte
impfstoff der übrigens auch eine
wirksamkeit bab a4 b5 hat anlässlich des
hausärzte tages warnen die mediziner vor
einer deutlich stärkeren grippewelle
diese saison nach zwei jahren niedriger
zahlen sei das immunsystem nicht gut
vorbereitet empfohlen wird den
risikogruppen eine doppel impfung wir
wollen gerne erreichen dass die menschen
sich gleichzeitig gegen korona boostern
lassen und gegen grippe impfen lassen
das passt gut zusammen man hat er nur
einen termin und ist gut geschützt für
herbst winter und das frühjahr über
60-jährige und menschen mit
vorerkrankungen sollten aktuell also
nicht nur über einen corona booster
nachdenken
jetzt nach schweden das land steht nach
dem knappen sieg der opposition bei der
parlamentswahl vor einem politischen
rechtsruck der vorsitzende der
konservativen moderaten sammlungspartei
christa sonne muss mit den
rechtspopulistischen schwedendemokraten
um parteichef akerson ausloten wie eine
zusammenarbeit im parlament möglich wäre
verlierer sind die sozialdemokratische
ministerpräsidentin
andersen und ihr linkes bündnis sie
holten nur 173 mandate das rechte lager
kamen auf 176 sitze heike kruse
sie zog heute die konsequenzen
ministerpräsidentin magdalena anders und
von den sozialdemokraten überreichte dem
parlamentspräsidenten das
rücktrittsschreiben das rechte parteien
bündnis hat das linke besiegt mit
hauchdünner mehrheit schweden ist ein
gespaltenes land geworden
ich finde das wahlergebnis gut ich habe
vertrauen was in den letzten jahren
passiert ist die vielen schießereien und
so ich glaube die neue regierung wird
was verändern
ich hatte auf ein anderes resultat
gehofft besonders die tatsache dass die
schwedendemokraten so stark geworden
sind macht mir angst große angst dass
jemand
eine mickey rourke sonst
rechtspopulistischen schwedendemokraten
triumphieren mehr als 20 prozent der
stimmen haben sie bekommen stärkste
kraft im konservativen blog ein
wichtiger faktor für den wahlerfolg die
ängste vor einwanderung und
bandenkriminalität in keinem anderen
land in europa sterben im verhältnis zur
bevölkerung mehr menschen an
schussverletzungen als in schweden laut
absprache im rechten bündnis vor der
wahl soll wulff christa sohn von den
moderaten ministerpräsident werden
nur die moderaten sind die partei die
das land wieder vereinen will wir werden
alles tun um die unterstützung für
reformen zu bekommen wir müssen auch die
energie krise bewältigen ist
die rechtspopulistischen
schwedendemokraten haben gute chancen
auf einen posten in der regierung aber
parteichef jimmie akesson als minister
oder gar ministerpräsident bislang kein
tabu im konservativen bündnis schweden
ist mit der wahl auf jeden fall ein
großes stück nach rechts gerückt
sie nehmen stundenlanges anstehen bei
wind und wetter in kauft tausende wollen
in london abschied nehmen von der
verstorbenen königin elizabeth der
zweite auch heute warteten die menschen
geduldig und das teils seit der nacht in
einer kilometerlangen schlange um zum
sarg der queen in westminster hall zu
gelangen die beisetzung der königin
findet am montag statt
deutschland wird zusätzliche 58
millionen euro pro jahr für
pflegebedürftige holocaust-überlebenden
israel bereit stellen eine entsprechende
vereinbarung wurde anlässlich eines
festaktes in berlin zum luxemburger
abkommen bekannt gegeben vor 70 jahren
verpflichtete sich die bundesregierung
unterstützung so und
entschädigungszahlungen an überlebende
des holocaust zu leisten bei der
gedenkveranstaltung bezeichnete
bundeskanzler scholz das abkommen von
1952 als moralisches fundament für
deutschland
hohe promidichte gestern abend in köln
getroffen haben sich die stars der
fernseh szene macherinnen und macher bei
der verleihung des deutschen
fernsehpreises
der dresscode sommerlich elegant das zdf
freute sich über insgesamt sechs preise
die journalistin katrin eigendorf wurde
in der kategorie beste information
eigenleistung ausgezeichnet giovanni
zarella bekam den fernsehpreis als
bester unterhaltungs moderator und iris
berben für ihr lebenswerk die stimmen
und bilder des abends von ina baltes
der höhepunkt kommt ganz zum schluss der
ehrenpreis fürs lebenswerk geht an iris
berben die dank vor allem gegen die
hinter den kulissen wird
ich bin sehr glücklich eine von euch zu
sein vielen dank
zuvor stand schon der sohn oliver berben
auf der bühne er hat für das zdf den
fernsehfilm des jahres produziert die
wannseekonferenz
durch den abend führt singend tanzend
und moderieren barbara schöneberger
nicht alle ihre gäste sind vor ort
zugeschaltet der beste schauspieler
moritz bleibtreu für die rtl-serie
fetting hitler beste schauspielerin ist
friederike becht für ihre rolle in dem
ard thriller schneller als die angst
also es heißt es kalt mir ist schlecht
um ist gleichzeitig geht's mir
wahnsinnig gut insgesamt gibt es 30
fernsehpreise in diesem jahr 15 davon
gehen an den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk tränen bei familie zarella
giovanni gewinnt den preis als bester
unterhaltungs moderator für die beste
persönliche leistung in der kategorie
information sind drei kriegsreporter
nominiert gewonnen hat katrin eigendorf
für das zdf zugeschaltet aus hakel wie
widmet ihren preis allen kollegen die in
diesen schwierigen zeiten aus der
ukraine berichten
so jetzt so fußball-champions-league
also vorgestern hat ja was ja ein
relativ erfolgreicher abend für die
klubs gestern eher nicht so wenig so rb
leipzig hat 0 2 bei real madrid verloren
und borussia dortmund 1 2 bei manchester
city und ausgerechnet er in hollern also
der der bis zur vergangenen saison seine
lust auf tore beim bvb gestellt hatte
sorgte für die entscheidung pro
manchester
außergewöhnliche spieler machen
außergewöhnliche tore der siegtreffer
von erling holland gegen seinen ex club
ist so eins außergewöhnlichen jubel
verkneift sich der norweger nach diesem
kunststück
ich habe glaube ich wirklich lange beine
deshalb bin ich an den ball gekommen
eine gute flanke und ich muss schon
sagen gutes tor
der bvb spielt gut gibt aber die führung
aus der hand die gut bellingham in der
56 minute erzielt in der 80 gleich sonst
uns aus nicht unhaltbar für keeper meyer
vier minuten später kommt holland der
bvb fährt mit null punkten heim
für die letzten beiden länderspiele vor
der fußball-wm hat bundestrainer hansi
flick überraschend den 20 jährigen
abwehrspieler arme bella kocak von fc
southampton in der englischen premier
league nominiert er steht im kader für
die nations league spiele gegen ungarn
und england in den kommenden zwei wochen
ja ein neuling kommt ein ganz großer
geht im tennis roger federer hat
angekündigt ende nächster woche beim
laver cup in london sein letztes turnier
auf der atp tour zu spielen mit 41
jahren 24 davon als profi und nach mehr
als 1500 spielen sei nun zitat zeit die
grenzen meines körpers zu erkennen ja
und nur noch einen sieg brauchen
deutschlands basketballer dann stehen
sie im finale bei der heim em gegner
morgen abend in berlin spanien
alle spieler sind fit im deutschen team
locker und heiß aufs halbfinale
und sie haben bei der heim-em bislang
basketball vom feinsten geboten nun
wartet der aktuelle weltmeister spanien
der sich zwar im umbruch befindet aber
dennoch auf hohem niveau spielt
das ist ein verdammt gutes spanisches
team alle spieler spielen in den beiden
wichtigsten ligen der welt die nur der
neuen spanischen generation um die
brüder willi und hörnern gomez steht
jedoch ein extrem entschlossenes und
eingespieltes team deutschland gegenüber
und das will nach 17 jahren endlich
wieder eine medaille gewinnen und sie
sagen auch ganz klar jetzt wollen wir
gold ich freue mich auf das spiel
dankeschön katja zum wetter schon mal so
viel es wird kühler mit schauern mehr
dazu gleich von ostentativ zum heute
journal um 21.45 begrüßt sie später
christian sievers unser gesamtes team
sagt danke fürs zuschauen tschüss und
schönen abend
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine kühle und nasse phase steht
uns bevor zwischen einem umfangreichen
tief über skandinavien dem hoch hier im
westen kommt kühle luft aus dem norden
und dies recht instabil so bilden sich
schauer und gewitter bereits in der
kommenden nacht im norden wird also
ungemütlich sein mit gewittern teilweise
ganz im süden gibt es regen oder im
westen auch und der wind an der nordsee
aus nordwestlichen richtungen teils
stürmisch dazwischen ist es trocken dass
bei tiefsten temperaturen von sieben
grad im vogtland oder im hessischen
bergland deutlich milder im südwesten
bei 14 grad morgen dann im tagesverlauf
schauer und gewitter im norden dazu
weiterhin kräftiger wind an der nordsee
im westen ebenfalls schauer und gewitter
zum nachmittag dann auch im süden ja
dazwischen gibt es einen breiten bereich
mit teils sonnenschein bei höchsten
temperaturen von 18 grad in der
niederlausitz und 13 grad im hessischen
bergland und die nächsten tage ziemlich
ungemütliches wetter mit weiteren
schauern und gewittern und unter 20 grad
ein schöner abend